the humble bumblebee fuzzy adorable in a
vital player in our ecosystem
responsible for pollinating crops across
the country but what happens when these
critical pollinators come in contact
with widely used pesticides researchers
set out to answer this question by
testing the behavioural effects of a
popular insecticide imidacloprid on
colonies of bumblebees they chose
bumblebees due to the size of their
colonies which are much smaller than
honeybee colonies making it easier to
observe individual bees to track their
behavior each bee was outfitted with its
own small waterproof 2d barcode that
would allow a robotic camera to record
the movement of each bee individually
the colonies were separated into
different tracking arenas each
consisting of a nesting area in a
foraging area the bees were given access
to nectar with varying concentrations of
imidacloprid similar to what they might
ingest out in the wild the scientists
used a camera mounted on a custom
robotic chassis to periodically check in
on each colony their findings were
striking within 24 hours colonies that
were exposed to the pesticide exhibited
a range of behavioral changes
the bees were lethargic and had fewer
social interactions the bees also forged
less and spread out from the center of
the nest towards the periphery of the
colony the researchers also wanted to
test insecticides effects under more
realistic conditions so they set up six
colonies outdoors equipped with thermal
sensors each colony was given access to
either pure nectar for nectar containing
imidacloprid the researchers measured
the surface temperature of the colony
and the air temperature inside and
outside the colony
they found that colonies that had
ingested the imidacloprid had trouble
regulating the temperature of the nest
especially as temperatures outside began
to dip these colonies were also less
likely to construct a protective wax
canopy around the developing young than
colonies that had eaten only pure nectar
these behavioural changes may seem small
but when combined they can have drastic
effects on the nest as a whole
researchers believe that this study
highlights the need for a better
understanding of how insecticides and
other agricultural chemicals and
negatively impact ecosystems
[Music]
you
[Music]